let's get into this week's email bag you
can email info davidpakman.com if you
have a question comment suggestion
correction
whatever really it's all welcome as long
as it's respectful let's get right into
the first one uh linda wrote in about
something i said about the noah's ark
story last week uh last week i said you
know one
i struggle with some of these stories
and fail to get answers when i say well
uh if there were two of every uh two of
every animal
um you had every kind of bird and every
kind of insect and you know we're
talking about millions of species how is
that possible or what did the
carnivorous animals eat whatever right
and linda wrote in and said actually
linda and or john
it says both names
and they say
according to genesis 1 29
man kind and animals were originally
vegetarians
the food was put in the arc per 6 22 and
in 9 1-5 after they landed god
instituted a new covenant and the eating
of meat this is the type of thing that
i'm kind of um
talking about because there's always
some explanation but it doesn't actually
make any scientific sense so like for
example in this case it's well the
animals were vegetarian at the time of
noah's ark
and then the animals started to eat meat
others will say well actually really
god's will and direction
really only applies to humans not to
animals so now now god is directing what
animals eat
the other counterpoint would be well if
this all happened in the last five or
six thousand years
there is number one no evidence that
currently carnivorous animals were ever
vegetarian and if the idea is they
evolved from being vegetarian to being
uh carnivorous
5 000 years is not nearly enough time
for that to happen to all of those
species so that also doesn't make sense
but i get that they don't believe in the
evolution piece anyway so it it all
doesn't make sense another email said
well
on noah's ark they were eating pickled
and dried meats the carnivorous animals
ate pickled and dried meats and that's
why
um the car the issue of
the animals that were alive being eaten
isn't an issue well but there's no
evidence of that another one was they
were all eating fish eggs i've not seen
any evidence of that uh the other one i
got was there david there were two of
each main species so like there were
just two snakes
and then later those two snakes became
all the subspecies
maybe that would be plausible if we were
talking about millions of years or
longer but if this all supposedly
happened in five or six thousand years
that doesn't make any sense so the point
here is they'll always come up with
something
um but there's no evidence for any of
the stuff and at a certain point you
have to say well what do i accept as
evidence and i've still not seen any
uh convincing explanation of the noah's
ark story okay next is michael michael
wrote in about people who don't talk
politics michael says there's people on
the right and left but mainly the right
who simply don't talk politics is there
a way to convince them why they need to
get out and vote these radical
conservatives out i think many of them
are republicans because it's passed down
so yes there's lots of people that are
republicans because they come from a
republican family in my experience the
best way to get people who aren't into
politics to follow politics is to say to
them okay i get it you just you don't
care about politics you don't care about
news it's boring you're just not
interested i totally get that that makes
sense there's so many things that that
what we can pay attention to tell me
what matters to you
they go well i don't know i like sports
and car driving or whatever else and go
no i understand that but you must think
there's some problems in the world
either in your immediate community or
with government or with that there must
be some problem they go well yeah i mean
i really hated that
whatever right something related to
climate or something related to a law of
legislation regulation of their business
whatever you go well you might not care
about politics but other people then are
deciding
how your business is regulated other
people are deciding how your immediate
parks that are around you are being
taken care of or not taken care of so
the point here is
people who aren't into politics
usually still have opinions about the
world around them and it's about just
explaining to them that it's the
political system that will impact
what happens and that that will often
work to get people to say oh i didn't
realize that
this thing i care about actually is
politics and i should be paying
attention and i should be involved give
it a shot let me know how it works
ozone wrote in saying about clarence
thomas
david sir
whatever happened to the ginny thomas
story the media seems to have lost
interest in it if this were a more
liberal judge in a similar situation
it's easy for me to see the mainstream
media and fox mentioning the story
constantly for days on end i would love
to hear your thoughts
on another note i've been a member over
a year now and love what you do you're
doing a great job keep it up thank you
so we have a situation where like every
week there's a pretty major scandal uh
during the trump presidency it was
basically every other day but now every
week or every couple of weeks there's
some big story we found out to find out
something crazy that mark meadows did or
jenny thomas did or whatever jenny
thomas was quite uh involved as a
supporter of the january 6th festivities
and
the story has basically gone away and i
think it's just an information overload
type of thing it's two things right-wing
media won't even talk about it
and then in addition even we on the left
and independent media we also have so
many things to talk about that we can't
keep every story in the forefront all
the time that's why it's good to have
lots of independent media outlets some
that specialize on legal stories some
that specialize in whatever but you're
completely right the story is kind of
gone and it may be gone forever
last week i asked about who's more
dangerous in a cult and the cult is
trumpism
the true believers or the false
believers who go yeah yeah the election
was stolen but they don't really believe
it but they say it to be part of the
team
silver wrote in
and said david i believe the false
believers are worse
it's similar to my understanding of the
difference between a drug addict and a
narcissist in other words the drug drug
addict displays narcissistic behavior
but is either unaware or does so to get
a fix
the narcissist likewise knows their
manipulate manipulative behavior pattern
but they don't care it is definitely a
difficult question but i believe of the
two that the one who knows their actions
could possibly be the worst of the two
uh is is the worst one so if i
understand correctly what silver is
saying is
the false believers
don't even believe this stuff
but still repeat it knowing that its
effect could be destructive and that
thus they are worse whereas the true
believer in the case of the big lie
thinks no the election was really stolen
so that's something we have to fix
and therefore they are less pernicious
i could be convinced of that
there's def there's definitely some
logic to that yeah that makes some sense
canadian paul wrote in about the
republican recently suggesting fauci be
killed
by firing squad
writing in stochastic fouchy firing
squad sir
i would like to add another
consideration to your coverage of the uh
p-u-y-a-s-o i don't know what that
acronym is john bennett and his
suggestion that dr fauci should face a
firing squad i believe this to be the
least common form of execution today but
it was used quite intentionally of the
74 million republican trump voters how
many have a gas chamber in their
basement an electric chair in their
living room or the chemistry background
to administer a lethal injection
now
how many have a gun
keep up the great work i think the point
that canadian paul is talking about here
is
if you want to get fouchy killed
and you go
fauci should be sent to the electric
chair
most trumpists don't have an electric
chair in their basement maybe some do
but most don't they don't have the means
to do the thing that's being suggested
but
uh many trumpists have a gun
and that's why he said firing squad that
canadian paul may be on to something it
may not have been an accident that the
term firing squad was used
steve wrote in about the pandemic and
steve says do you really think states
are honestly reporting covet cases i
don't for one second think the reports
are honest from all states not even
close so the the answer is no
but there's two parts to this one are
there states that are deliberately
hiding coveted cases at this point maybe
i mean listen probably there's 50 states
there's you could probably find an
example of some official somewhere
who is uh limiting
the higher numbers from being published
it's probably true
the bigger issue is now a lot of people
who have symptoms don't even get tested
so they just don't show up in the
numbers and a lot of people who do a
home test and test positive never report
it and so of course the numbers are
lower
in i'm still hearing some reports that
say the real case numbers are two
to three times higher than what is being
reported but it's not necessarily
because the numbers are being lied about
it's people are testing at home or not
testing and none of that ever makes it
into the case numbers
next email is about uh dan bongino and
my pronunciation
dan bongino you disappointed me
hi david i love your show keep up the
great work started watching your show a
few months ago because you're fair and
you explain things with data
you disappointed me when you pronounce
dan bongino's name incorrectly the i
is pronounced as a long e and not an i
bongino
i only bring this up because you go on
all the people that pronounced the new
supreme court nominee's name incorrectly
which is great and i agree with you 100
to paraphrase you said something like
come on guys get the name right
you actually said maybe they're doing it
on purpose maybe they don't know how to
pronounce it you did the exact same
thing with danbongino so david were you
making fun of dan's name
or did you really not know how to
pronounce it i'm sure a lot in the
audience as i do await your answer keep
up the great work
what do you guys think do you guys think
i know
it's not pronounced bongino
do you think i know it's not pronounced
tulsi gabbard
you think i know it's not pronounced
jimmy dore
let me know
let me know i think the answer will
become very evident
philip wrote in a quick correction and
this i love this i love being corrected
on this stuff we talked about the
betting odds for candidates you can go
on the website predict it
and you can bet monies
who will be the republican nominee you
can bet on anything you want and philip
wrote in and said david you described it
as 70 cents of every dollar bet to
describe the process of betting using
the predicted prediction markets in
reality the prices are the cost of a
contract that settles at either a dollar
or nothing
not the amount of every dollar bet on
that market it's the cost of a contract
not the volume might be pedantic but i
know david values accuracy no i
appreciate that when you go on to
predict it it'll say for example
70 cents next to donald trump i wrongly
said that means 70 cents
70 percent of the dollars bet are being
bet on trump being the nominee that's
wrong
uh but i think if i understand correctly
you have to bet 70 cents
to end up making a dollar because it's
relatively likely that it will be trump
whereas on a long shot candidate you
might only have to bet 5 cents to make a
dollar if you're right i think that
that's the correct way i'm not a big
betting guy but i appreciate the
correction okay lastly and guys this is
just an instructive thing on things i
can't do
sunday night owen wrote to me
and said hey david i'm late on a part
that's due for my paper
it's a persuasive essay we could choose
any topic so i chose why corporate money
should be taken out of politics i need
counter arguments to that point i was
wondering if you knew
any to make it easier on me
guys i can't help you with your homework
okay you would be surprised at how often
i get stuff like this you gotta do your
own work i can't number one this was due
the next day
um
you know
even if you thought i could help you
with your homework if you email me
sunday night for monday homework i
obviously can't help you
number two i don't have the ability or
where with all and resources to respond
to the emails that i get and number
three do your own work owen please this
is a very important life lesson do your
own work i'm begging you all right we
have a great bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpacman.com you'll get
instant access it'll be a beautiful
thing you can use the coupon code
obama
remember that obama obama
yeah you can use that as a coupon code
to get a discount when you sign up and
we'll see you on the bonus show